el candidato del 2018 hoy presidente de
la república fue ser un candidato del
centro democrático y el candidato del
centro democrático esta vez fue óscar
iván zuluaga en una consulta interna
no muy clara si en el procedimiento y en
los resultados y cuando sale la consulta
el resultado de la consulta de la
coalición de centroderecha
unidos por colombia creo que se llamaba
equipo porque por colombia a mí me
sorprendió que muy rápidamente el
calidad tres días y hubiera declinado y
renunciaba a su candidatura porque le
dejó abierta la
bola la autopista a federico gutiérrez
que entró en un dilema muy complicado no
se podían mover mucho a la derecha
entonces él nunca sale en la foto con
uribe digamos antes todo el mundo se
tomaba la foto con uribe hoy nadie
quiere tomarse la foto con uribe ni él
mismo y también tenía que tomar
distancia del gobierno actual pero las
estructuras políticas que lo empezaron a
apoyar en las regiones pues sí son
digamos atados a esas a esas a esas dos
dinámicas y a la dinámica un poco lo
mismo de la dinámica del gobierno yo
creo que quedó como en un como en un
sánduche por llamarlo de alguna manera
en las últimas en las últimas semanas el
trato de cambiar un poco el discurso de
decir yo no soy uribista yo no soy a la
continuidad yo quiero unir al país yo
quiero trabajar bueno apenas me
posesioné voy a invitar a la ciudad a
petro a rodolfo a fajardo a que trabajen
conmigo a construir país yo creo que ya
y no en el discurso no le dio no le dio
para eso y agregaría que en los debates
no le fue bien sí yo creo que en los
debates demostró mucha debilidad poca
preparación para los temas de estado da
la sensación de que siempre le estaban
orientando en la respuesta a las
preguntas las respuestas eran evasivas
siempre resultaban por algo concreto
cuál es su política económica por decir
la violencia no es que petro dijo que
tal cosa y entonces no decía no usted
viene aquí a los debates a discutir con
petro pero cuál es su propuesta yo creo
que todos esos factores fueron fueron
dándose y
los resultados de las encuestas de las
últimas semanas mucha gente que estaba
apoyando a federico gutiérrez dijeron no
esté en segunda vuelta no es una buena
carta para derrotar a gustavo petro
vámonos con el ingeniero rodolfo que ese
sí que ese sí puede derrotarlo en
segunda porque en los escenarios que
salía de intención de voto- segunda
vuelta entre rodolfo y petro había un
empate mientras que entre petro y
federico había una distancia importante
yo creo que muchos dijeron eso no es
nuestro candidato ya no funcionó y en
segundo a quien le puede ganar por eso
fue digamos se juntaron todos los
factores adversos por decirlo de alguna
manera y se fundió la candidatura de
modo digamos desde el grupo político que
lleva poniendo presidentes desde el 2002